[موسيقى]
يجب أن تكون هذه الهدنة خطوة أولى
لإنهاء الحرب اليمنية المدمرة
لوقف القتال إلى جانب دخول
سفن كاملة واستخدام القيود
على حركة الأشخاص
والبضائع داخل البلاد وخارجها
سيسهم في بناء الثقة و
خلق بيئة مواتية
لاستئناف المفاوضات من أجل تسوية سلمية
للنزاع ، من
المقبول أن يوقف الطرف جميع
العمليات العسكرية الجوية والبحرية الهجومية
داخل اليمن
وعبر حدودها
، كما وافقوا على دخول سفن الوقود
إلى موانئ الحديدة ورحلات تجارية
للعمل.  داخل وخارج
مطار صنعاء للتحديد المسبق للوجهات
في المنطقة
وافق الأجانب على الاجتماع تحت
رعاية المبعوثين الخاصين لفتح الطرق في تايلاند
ومحافظات أخرى في اليمن
ويمكن تجديد الهدنة بعد
فترة الشهرين بموافقة الطرفين
ودعا السيد جرينبيرج الأطراف إلى
الالتزام التام بالهدنة
وعناصرها واحترامها واتخاذ جميع الإجراءات
اللازمة.  eps لتنفيذه على الفور